they tried to do well in the bubble was
you know how when you would wake up
you'd have to do the questionnaire and
like the very last question they say is
like do you want to speak to a mental
health professional today yeah and i
thought that was like a really nice
thing that they did because it was hard
for so many people and
when i've done interviews i talked about
it i talked to jimmy butler about
therapy i just talked to michael jordan
about therapy and they all said like i
have tried this and it has helped me
michael b said that he still does it is
that something that you would try i
think you know eventually i would um
normally like i'm just so used to
either getting through it myself or just
talking to my fam right or like my you
know my close people like i don't trust
a lot of people you know with
with certain stuff so i feel like that's
why i haven't yet but i mean right now i
feel like you know
my life is good like totally i'm happy
i'm enjoying it
just gotta stay right there yes that's
what i say you always have a smile on
your face yeah you're always smiling
it's a lot behind a smile but right now
it's all smiles